virginia
the zip code is two four five zero four
we're looking at an american air force
airplane landing in hanoi vietnam and
with us in the studio watching us at the
same time is francis wenig who is staff
director of the senate select committee
on p-o-w m-i-a affairs
francis sweeney
you remember that trip
very well still still
thinking back with the light on that
trip and that plane we were looking at
is what
it's um an air force plane that was
assigned um to our committee
for a fact-finding mission that took
place in april this year we went to uh
several countries started out in
thailand then we went to cambodia then
to vietnam
then to laos and then to hong kong and
back to the states what was the purpose
of the trip it's part of the mission of
the committee to do what we can in the
year allotted to us to find out
what the present policy is with respect
to pod to pows american pows are there
still live americans in southeast asia
and what is being done to answer that
question and what has the government
done over the past 20 years to answer
that question how big was this
delegation that's arriving on this video
tape in hanoi we had a party of 16
people included five senators and
accompanying staff which senators the
senators were the chairman senator john
kerry
the vice chairman senator bob smith from
new hampshire
and three other members of the 12
members of the committee senator hank
brown from colorado senator chuck
grassley from iowa and senator chuck
robb from virginia any idea of the 12
members of your select committee how
many of them are vietnam veterans i
believe there are
four
who actually served in vietnam
do you remember how long it took you to
get to this point in your trip i mean
when did you leave the united states and
how long did it take to get to hanoi we
actually did two back-to-back red-eyes
we left
washington andrews air force base
thursday night flew all night arrived in
hawaii for um
for a day's briefing
at with the sink pack folks the
pacific command
and then got back on the plane that
night
and did another red eye
and arrived in bangkok the equivalent of
sunday morning
and then went into another day of
briefings and you had been to cambodia
before you stopped here
no we went
we had been yes we had been through
bangkok for the one day of briefings
and then we went to cambodia for a day
and met with the government officials
there the pow team we actually
interviewed a woman who gave us a live
sighting report
and
we're still evaluating that report
what does it mean when you say a live
sighting the woman reported to us that
she had been in vietnam and she had
talked
with a live american
the woman's
testimony was didn't bear up under much
scrutiny even our our own questioning
but
well the count it was evidence of the
the good efforts of the cambodian
government that they wanted to produce
this woman they didn't believe her but
they wanted us to judge for ourselves
again looking at a 707 actually in
military terms i guess it's not called a
707 but it's in boeing aircraft
senator kerry senator smith and
who else travel with you besides you and
senator grassley and senator brown
senator rob but i mean on this trip did
you have many staff we had a about about
10 10 staffers in addition to that the
the deputy staff director the staff
council some of our investigators and we
had
our press secretary and an escort
officer how long did you stay in hanoi
we stayed in hanoi
one and a half days
and the the second part of the second
day we traveled outside of hanoi to
visit
a
prison facility i believe you have some
footage of that that was a
we were following up on a live sighting
report with next to no notice
given to the vietnamese it was a
fascinating trip because it showed
a couple of things that showed
the
we pushed the edge of the envelope with
that prison visit we showed that
the system developed by the cooperation
between the vietnamese and the american
government let us go to that point and
we you as you'll see from the footage
they were not prepared to let us see the
whole prison but through negotiations
and pushing and cajoling and reasoning
after two hours they let us view the
whole prison who's the gentleman that
you've just met there and he'll be in
the screen here off to the right in a
moment i hope he's the nor he's the
vietnamese official that greeted you at
the bottom of the steps there i'm sorry
i missed
i'm sorry he was the main he was your
main contact point the one that also
went to the mekong delta and that was mr
fong he's a deputy director of the
department of the americas and he
very effectively acted as an advocate on
our part you'll see
as a as you watch the footage
that um
there are parts of the vietnamese
government that aren't so willing to
help out and they're parts that want to
help out and you'll see that mr fong
acted as an advocate on our behalf to
push
the our
are getting into the prison to push our
getting to the prison um onto the
military bases to get answers who's the
gentleman getting in the front there
is back to us who's got a
uh the translator andre sovijo
uh he's a former colonel he served many
many
terms in vietnam presently now he works
in um out of bangkok with the vietnamese
refugees in hong kong who they're trying
to persuade to go back
to vietnam his vietnamese is excellent
how many trips like this has a select
committee made to vietnam this is the
first trip this year to vietnam senator
kerry and senator smith
have actually been to vietnam before and
so they're following up on some of their
early efforts on behalf of families and
veterans to get
more answers to the questions about what
happened to the american pows and mias
what was the number one
benefit to going to hanoi in your
opinion besides the prison visit you
mentioned earlier
i would say that
the presence of five united states
senators
the largest delegation of senators
underscored to the vietnamese as well as
the cambodians as well as the oceans the
importance this government and this
country places on getting the answers to
the questions about what happened to
americans who were pows or mia's in
vietnam laos and cambodia
how did you personally get into this in
the first place
well i've been involved with
southeast asian questions since i was a
peace corps volunteer in thailand 20
years ago by the way on the screen there
is also a play in the background it says
malaysia on it air malaysia flies into
hanoi and saigon they have quite a bit
in fact while we were in hanoi the prime
minister of malaysia was there
with a 40-person trade delegation
meeting with the vietnamese government
what's the life span of the committee
how long are you going to be in business
it's a select committee which means what
the select committee it means it is a
leadership committee it was appointed by
senators george mitchell and bob dole
the democratic republican leaders of the
senate
the lifespan of the committee is is the
end of this congress we run out on
january 2nd 1993.
and we we propose to do all of our work
by them we have a very ambitious
schedule but we plan to to complete our
work how many hearings have you had
until now we've had three hearings we've
had a visit uh to moscow to follow up
questions about moscow bound we've
senators carrie and smith been appointed
members of the u.s russia commission
which has already met twice
and we're pursuing questions of world
war ii and korea which is part of our
mandate as well what's the political
makeup of the select committee it's half
and half this is not a partisan
committee we have six republicans and
six democrats there's not a partisan
cast to the answering the questions
about what happened how many staff
members does the whole select committee
have we have 21 staff members and in the
end what can the american people see
that they can put their hands on that
will be some kind of a report on this
we're planning to do a report but your
show is very much a part of what this
committee is all about we want to open
this process up that's been a problem in
the past
there have been questions raised and
questions not answered both
of the vietnamese laotians and
cambodians and of our own government and
what we're trying to do as a committee
is to open the process up we were very
pleased that c-span was able to go along
on this trip we were pleased that the
that the governments in southeast asia
allowed the press in the meetings
allowed you to accompany us on our
mission
there are many
questions that are not yet answered but
we want to try to open the process up
and let people judge for themselves how
many more hearings will you have before
you complete your work before you write
the report well i'm not going to
prejudge what we're going to find as we
do our investigation so i don't want to
limit ourselves as far as hearings but
we will have at least
three or four or five more hearings
before the end of the time
as well as put out a report you brought
to all this i got here in my notes a
couple of years in the peace corps in
thailand
how did you get into this whole business
in the first place where are you from
well i grew up all over the south i grew
up mainly in tennessee and georgia
but i went to school in virginia and
massachusetts it's just a logical
progression of all the work i've done in
the past i'm the viet i'm of the vietnam
generation so this is um
an attempt at answering questions that
were raised when i was in college and
still have not been answered you went to
william and mary better get that in the
fletcher school of law and diplomacy
which is what it's a it's a graduate
school uh for people interested in in
diplomacy diplomatic service and duke
law school
why do you what good is it do to have a
law degree in a job like this what's the
importance of it well i think it's
important to understand um how our laws
are made and that what better way to
learn that
than through going to law school but it
it's um but i guess what i was getting
at is are you going to write legislation
out of this select committee uh
it's conceivable in fact we had a
meeting this morning talking about uh
the whole question of declassification
are the laws in the books right now
adequate to deal with a problem of
opening up the records that have been
kept by our government over the past few
years if they're not then we have to try
to do fast-track legislation between now
and when the congress goes out on
declassification how emotional is this
for people that you're dealing with from
the american public there's a lot of
emotion obviously the families
uh have been
um
not well served by this process
the fact that 20 years later we still
have these kind of questions that are
not answered it's not it's not a good
not a good judgment on our on our
government there are people who've
worked on this issue for 20 years and
there's both in the government and
outside the government so there's an
emotional investment there
there are veterans who
want to know what happened to the people
that they fought with
there's a lot of emotion before we go
back to uh hanoi on tape what how would
you recommend that people watch these
next several hours what should they look
for what should they listen to in the
words of senator carrier senator smith
or any of the senators along
the
questions that people should ask are
what is
is there does there seem to be an
attempt to
to answer questions is there an attempt
to open up
uh open up the process and just people
should just judge for themselves how
open these governments seem to be
whether the senators seem to be
answering the right questions
and
things might occur to people as they
watch this that might not have occurred
to us we can go back if there if there
are things that should be asked
please let us know
there we didn't answer every question we
weren't totally satisfied with this trip
but we think it was a good beginning we
pushed the edge of the envelope
and it's now up to our government our
government representatives veterans
families to follow up to make sure that
the openings that we got
stay open francis winning staff director
of the senate select committee on pow
mia affairs thank you
let's go back on videotape to the hanoi
airport
[Music]
nice to see you again how are you
remember
you do
remember each other that's right
thank you for meeting us nice to see you
again
sir you're in the lead vehicle and this
one's right here senator grassley and
senator smith sir you're in the second
vehicle okay
i'm glad you're out here
shortly i want to chat with you yes sir
as soon as we can yeah
so maybe right when we get in we can
spend a minute
good all right here we go we all set yes
sir okay okay
how are you doing here
what's
up francis do you have the other bag
[Music]
oh these are my biking glasses northern
virginia bike trails
it's all right
70 k's a day in and out from reston
virginia this guy is incredible last
time i was here
he'd be out early in the morning in
these tight jogging shots and i'd be out
there talking to everybody in the
streets
yeah he's still pleasant he's incredible
he managed today every day
oh yeah so you heard our comments yeah
on voice of america
did they meet with approval or
disapproval
yes
[Music]
and they prepared very
closely to meet the best conditions for
you for your delegation
to
to look at the situation in vietnam
well we uh as you know from the
communication that we sent you this is a
very important trip with great
possibilities
and he hopes that this trip will play a
constructive role
in the development of a better
relationship between our two countries
and they have followed with great
interest your delegations progress
and they understand and appreciate the
important role of the united states
congress in its relation to helping the
american people solve the problem of the
missing in action
and understanding that then it's
incumbent on them to try to create the
conditions for you
however he is sorry that your time here
is so short for such an important
mission
so for that reason we're going to start
in to work immediately this afternoon
[Music]
we're ready to go to work right now yeah
right now yes and he said that also
they're ready to start right away uh
with the uh
at 1400 with the foreign minister
windmin come and
and then of course
we may be here for a brief time
ourselves our senators
but the teams will be here through the
next few months
and we will be sending some people back
here to follow up on that work
[Music]
and they are just perfectly happy to
receive your specialist and your other
personnel to continue this work
we will have some uh requests with
respect to the visits that we want to
make in country
in the next two days and we'll try to
sit down with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what he'd like to propose is that he
show you
the proposed schedule that they've put
together based on what they received
from you in washington
but then there's perfectly happy then to
discuss from that any modifications or
supplementations that you might wish to
make
so when we get into the hotel senator uh
he said that that is the place to
discuss this
the re the schedule in the hotel yeah
if you see that it's getting hot out
here in the sun you recommend we go into
the air-conditioned office i like it
anybody else
that air conditioning drives me nuts
that's i'm glad there's one hey general
they're extremely nervous about the
physics
yeah he's a straight shooter
and he's been
able to get his job done by being
low-key but
staying after stand with his knitting
yeah
bob if we get some sites that we want to
ask for if they make the availability
we'll have the information on that by
the end of the day
yes
you went to some sites here in town
didn't you yeah on your previous visit
i went to uh leynon day street which was
the one garwood sighting as well at two
garwood sightings i think as well as the
mortician
testimony regarding the
alleged
uh storage of remains we visited that
site
that was been 1986 i think last time i
was here not that wasn't the last time i
was here with absolutely this that's
so we'll have
at least two maybe three very specific
locations we want to look at based on
what our investigators
determine
and we're going to
just ask them literally to go there the
right buildings
this is the stuff we had in the states
or stuff we got uh
stuff we had in the states
we've still got the sink mixed up too
yes we have all of that stuff too yeah
and based upon his statement we ought to
be able to do that without any
any problem i don't think you know until
you you don't know you don't know until
you get out there
well let's hope that we get to the
bottom
get used to the heat
it takes a while to acclimatize
and we stepped off the plane just about
took your breath away yeah it takes a
while to get used to it but hanoi ought
to be better i would think hanoi is uh
hotter than saigon
is it
hanoi
no saigon is hotter oh yeah it can be
hotter than this
we never
you just
i'd like to make sure that we've got
that message conveyed right
sure yeah
um
didn't even have anybody there
they had sufficient remains to identify
everyone else on the plane except the
last person and they had extra extra
remains
and based on the fact that they had
extra remains that didn't go with any of
the other people who are on the crash
they believe those remains were
associated with that last individual
although they could not make a positive
identification
i mean how would that information be
both available to and picked up by this
group of uh
fraudulent
uh
where are they getting they've said the
name henderson has been circulating
around quite a bit
but i mean since it wasn't listed on a
discrepancy case
why would it still be uh because dog
tags were recovered someone did someone
took the dog the dog tags came in later
yeah somewhere someone in vietnam hands
those dogs okay that would make sense
and there's recording being based on
those dogs that name is a name that is
circulating in the dog community
the the writing does appear to be not
only stilted but it does look like
something you see in others is that the
same
individual who's cranking out all those
letters
we can't tell yet we just got that
letter on friday they just gotten that
letter they need to go compare that to
other reporting on this henderson person
and see if that matches some of the
previous reports if they could track
right back down to the sources they
might be able to uncover several of the
web fraud promoters and put all that to
an end if they could right that's what
they're going to try to do dia
keeps a database
important on
every individual to get some sort of dog
tag important or whatever and they're
going to give us a printout of all the
different reporting that's been done
with that name
and that'll be interesting to see how
many people did you review the the three
cases that sync pack gave us for hanoi
and for i don't have a city
i don't have those i think bill kadena
has those cases
i thought if they're going to do
anything at all today i would like to
[Music]
office the vietnamese office for seeking
missing persons
those are the people who
who have the right needs an important
part of this conference but i'll ask
bill how they're going to work that in
i think you know they've got but they
don't have anything scheduled before
1400 we're wasting
three or four hours have we got anything
that we can initiate
on our own here you know
you have been here before have you got
or you haven't been
here
to build a new future and relationship
uh now and in the future
they believe there is no issue
that we cannot resolve if we work
honestly together in the spirit of
mutual trust all of these things can be
resolved
[Music]
but we are ready to
so
if we are truthful
and you are truthful
and you tell us everything you know and
we tell you everything we know we go
home and the issue will be done
foreign
uh he believes that that is exactly what
they have been doing and their intention
is to continue doing it
okay
because it is in the
interest of vietnam
to have a
good relationship with the united states
of america therefore it is enlightened
self-interest that motivates this
cooperation
and so to pursue any other course for
vietnam would be short-sighted and
superficial
um
but the political orientation of the
vietnamese top leadership is not
myopic and is not superficial it is long
uh
so when it comes to the details they're
prepared to do whatever it takes to
implement that overall
sophisticated and long-term
strategy and relationships
but that is not to say that there are
not remaining sensitivities on both
sides left over from the war because
there are
within the among the vietnamese people
and they try the government is trying to
overcome
the uh residual
sensitivities among the vietnamese
people remaining from the war but they
hope that you will be helpful to them in
overcoming the those sensitivities we
want we want to talk with you
i know you have to go we want to talk
with you about those sensitivities and
go all the way back to the paris peace
accords
all right
every time you start handling one of
those and it's a new way to wrap it and
you look like yeah it's like these
medicine bottles protected against
children opening them or something
that's never easy
i'm sorry it's important
because
there's a lot more mechanical amplitude
than i do
actually basically she's just smuggling
but i can move the piano and just stuff
like that and she can't thank you
[Music]
[Music]
merry christmas
[Music]
because the delegation is going to go
from five members to four members
i had a commitment
back in the united states that was made
well before this book was planned but i
could not change i hope that we were
going to come in february i hope that we
were going to come earlier in this week
neither of those worked out so i have to
leave tomorrow i'll be going tomorrow
out of commercial aviation
so i will only basically be here for
today's program
uh and i hope to have an opportunity to
come back i would particularly like to
go back to the area
where i'm
familiar with then you want to go to
south vietnam i will not go to south
vietnam and i very much regret it
yeah that's that would be very
meaningful for me personally
but
i'm only one member of the delegation
my schedule does not control so i just
wanted to know that it was not
intentional
and and i will be working with the other
five members uh the other four members
that are here as well as the full
committee when we get back and we're all
going to be sharing the information that
is derived here as well as additional
information that is being made available
through the visits to
other indochina countries as well as
through the testimony that uh chairman
kerry and vice chairman smith and the
rest of the uh participants uh have been
eliciting over this long period of time
i hope to come back i would like to
spend more time i'd like to spend time
in the north i'd like to see you all i
won't come to vietnam i would like to
come back
last time i was here i was i was a
diawee
yeah captain captain he's been promoted
that's right yeah
you're from where yes i am
no my mother is living there now but it
is
six
[Music]
immediately following their arrival at
the hanoi airport the senators traveled
by car to the tangloi hotel on the
outskirts of hanoi city for a meeting
with vietnamese officials the purpose of
the meeting to come to an agreement on
the agenda for the senator's time in
vietnam
we pick up the trip as senators kerry
smith rob grassley and brown check in at
the tangloi hotel
last time we stayed we stayed in town
but because the malaysians are here
we're sort of right on the edge
this is
thank you very much for coming
would you like to go to that room over
there so we've been uh
over our schedule
oh all right well should we get
ourselves
check in first personally you want to go
to this we'll check in yes
okay is that all right with you okay
what are we supposed to be doing we're
gonna check in well then then we're
gonna get together and meet with bill
bell okay
thank you
here
um
[Music]
taken off half of this myself
have you seen the other thing that's
smith nope
thank you for your patience
so
we would like to invite you and to
inform you about this schedule
first of all i would like to be
on behalf of my prime minister to
welcome
you to vietnam to hanoi
is
more
appropriate to have my minister lemaitre
to come today but
unfortunately he is in bali indonesia
today
so
i am working on behalf of him with you
to inform you about the schedule and
then to receive some more you know
requests from you and to see whether we
can put all together in
one day or more one day with this guest
we intend to you know meet every you
know request from the delegation but
because of the time so please we will
work together to arrange so how you can
benefit most of your visits of your time
in vietnam to find more information that
you need
so
the schedule we have worked out here
we
got information from our
mission in new york
to inform us that you would like to see
[Music]
some of our leaders
some of our
specialists
and visit some of the areas that just
keep in mind
so we try you know to arrange for all
that
first today in the afternoon at about
14
15.
14 15.
you will have a meeting with the
foreign minister
the foreign minister will cover you know
everything
you want to ask
about the
mia
issues
about the relation between our two
countries
and some other people
after that
at 16 we will meet the
defense minister
and his
the dependent minister and his office
the dependent minister now you know
is
the ministry that most of the activity
on mia we are working with
the archives the information
everything so it is very important to
talk to him and to ask him any question
you would like to raise
and then at 17
we will have a meeting with the justice
minister fanhead now his position is
justice minister but he was the one
participating in the paris
talk
and now he's the chairman of
vietnam american society
a
society that
would like to preach you know the two
people to get there so in that capacity
he would like to talk to you and if you
ask him about the
information related to the paris
agreement before
you should raise beautifully
can i ask you yes
just uh to ask you
when we meet with the
minister with responsibilities for the
paris peace talks will we also have
will we have uh
some of the other individuals who were
there in paris with whom i've met
previously
i think that we would we will
and any other individuals who were there
when uh
uh for now i i i know that madame bin
will be in that meeting former foreign
minister tyke uh no
we have an opportunity to meet with
former foreign we will ask that but uh
for now we arranged for you to meet
uh minister here at
tahyan and madabid
two of them participated in the parish
uh do you have a sense
of what uh former minister tyke's
availability will be
oh i've been asked that i think that
he's not covered know the
issues at the at the moment i know i
know he isn't at the moment i'm
interested historically
there's a certain historical background
that we're trying to put together and
it's important obviously
some of the people we've requested to
see
go back a certain amount of time
and they're not any longer in official
positions but they are very important to
helping us to understand
what happened in the past
um
okay we've been you know we're going to
see that but
at least we will have two you know
people working in the parish of women
here
and here
no i understand
no yes let me let me emphasize i do not
need to see uh foreign minister tyke at
that particular hour i could meet him
later i could meet him tomorrow morning
there's flexibility in terms of when we
would see him
thank you
or anything yeah just are any of uh lay
doctor's staff people still around that
could be available to talk regarding the
person i think that panhandle is the one
you know working very closely with
little town
in the paris agreement
uh we have our you know
that nearby
you know is the
one of the key stuff
but now he's the ambassador to
canada ken he is well we meet with him
there
yeah you know him you know i see him in
washington he got to come down thank you
um
and then
with the
at about 18 you will have a meeting with
the general hong kong he is the
director of the institute for military
history he knows
a lot about
campaign some history in
the war so you can ask
and then at 17 we arrange for you to
meet the man who is in charge of bw
during the war
uh mr
e e correct right
excuse me and you here i heard that you
would like to see some others yeah uh we
will have to you know ask the different
ministry whether they are available
that's the military law unit
let's go back to the military
law unit i think we had requested from
new york
through the ambassador
and that's a very important uh meeting
from our
perspective
particularly
maybe we will ask them today
and when you when you meet with the
department minister
you you may raise this question with him
because he you know has all the power to
have his gun on the
left and corner everyone to see you you
know that's what we need that is that is
why we consider the meeting with the
department minister it's very important
good thank you can we return in six
o'clock meeting um the suggestion was
made that we split into two groups
perhaps then i think we should i think
we should maximize we can divide up into
three groups that is we have the in mind
that you should divide the two or three
we're prepared to do that yeah and uh in
addition
if we can't get to somebody today
the most important thing for us is to
have a guarantee and assurance
that we can see that person
to have the minister of defense or
interior or the general secretary
make certain that we leave here with an
agreement
that those people will be accessible and
we can have staff
available or on a return oh that
trip that's that's a great relief for me
because you know we and you know some of
them may not not be here i understand
other problems they retire
so i understand you can have staff to
meet them later on the key is this is
the beginning we understand the
limitations but
it must be able to be done within the
next few months that's the critical
effect that that's
but back to the the six o'clock we could
senator rob would like to go to the war
museum and we could send some people to
the war museum and also perhaps visit
the archives
at that point
you think that's good
i may ask
yeah they stay open the warm museum will
be closed at about uh closest to three
three o'clock in the afternoon we could
do that so senators
you would like to go i think that after
this meeting given how lunch on the new
before meeting with the prime minister
that's fine that may be fine that's fine
you're fine
you go there and then
where is lunch well i think we're here
but we have we still have the problem of
the
is our lunch years are the formal ones
well then there's no reason that we
can't just go into town
why don't we just do that
um
terry has a good suggestion
why don't we just go it
what we will do is after this meeting
we'll leave and go into town into the
city yeah we'll eat lunch at a
restaurant yes and we will go to the war
museum immediately senator rob yeah we
would like to try to see the archives
yeah so
the the whole delegation
or some of you the whole delegation will
go into the city
correct and senator rob would like to
visit the museum
if there are a few minutes it it's uh
and it seems to me that that would be
the logical place to do it right uh just
before the meeting with the foreign
minister
but but the the archives are important
there's some at the war museum there's
some they're
various places is there is there an
opportunity to visit some archives and
to look at cases in the world museum
so we can
no matter well
with respect to our meetings uh today
that we've requested
the ones we had requested previously
through new york
um i would like to make certain that we
can meet with the
mr holyand
and mr fanbaa
from the cp 72
they were involved in the paris peace
talks
uh so we may
um i arranged for you to go there at
about
eight o'clock no it would have to be
earlier because he's got two well that
would be a short visit in any event yeah
very short you know only five minutes
yeah okay and then the senator can go
out and go right into his car and go to
the airport we'd have to leave earlier
if he leave for the flight
9 20
then
at about
you can leave i know well if your
statement is still
relevant for tomorrow morning you've got
a meeting
with the deputy minister for home to
affairs
we could do it immediately prior to that
meeting and i i the rest of the
delegation i think would be interested
probably in doing that as well so if we
leave here at 7 30 can we accomplish
everything
um
7 30. if we leave at 7 30 it takes how
many minutes to go to the mausoleum
about 15 minutes but they open at about
eight o'clock they can't open early
and then so can we be late for this
meeting yeah we will postpone by meeting
you
but you can go and then you will go to
here so we leave at 7 45.
and during the
the morning you know stress and tomorrow
you will
have some
other meetings
well let me originally tomorrow
there had been a visit to the prison
that's it correct
what i would like to request is if if we
could change that and go to the time
tree area
could we go down uh tomorrow 20th
country
thank you
[Applause]
i understand we could go by car it's
about 30 miles though about 30 clicks
is it better to go by helicopter
okay we've been asked you know
yeah
now that is after the meeting with the
the prime minister of the interior
or you might divide that would be well
what time is the meeting with the
minister of interior
all right
so we could just go straight from there
conceivable
okay and you may
want to see some other people like
if we wanted some people to go there
what is the possibility if we wanted to
put a test
to the question of live citing reports
we ask who the minister of defense
uh
if you want to ask you asked the
minister of
interior
minister of interior would be
responsible for that
he can have his people to go with you
and
sorry the last time mr novan and mr
morgan have been there
it's my understanding that in the
meeting with secretary solomon
in the five-point agreement yeah it was
agreed that there would be an immediate
capacity to go yeah we have a helicopter
right now for you to go anywhere so in
that brisbane we are ready to to to
offer to go
what time would we be able to do that in
the morning uh tomorrow
uh in the morning so it's my
understanding because instead of going
to visit because if you go to tech back
you have to go back
helicopter yeah we're not right and
you're not going to do that two people
might go no it's possible that some
people would go okay
but we would like to be able to reserve
the judgment as to where we're going to
go it was my understanding that we can
go anywhere is that correct yes yes so
what i'd like to do is make our decision
as to where we'd like to go
and then uh if it isn't ending from us
and then inform you and try to do it i
think it'd be very helpful to the
process obviously
a lot of people are are
curious about the access
and the capacity to go anywhere
so i think it's very helpful to us
as senators and as a select committee to
be able to make a request and see
exactly how it works
that'd be helpful
thank you
and then
the most important meeting will be at
half past the
10th
tomorrow as you will be received by the
secretary general yeah
he is
[Music]
had to say i don't know but he received
you two times already
at this time they asked us very much why
the delegation used to be meeting the
general secretary we think that is
he is the highest you know authority in
the country
he you know therefore it's important for
you to
meet him
to put any request you have in mind to
him and he can have his you know
order to the prime minister to interior
ministry to the
[Music]
premier or to the foreign ministry
we are all under him we very much
appreciate that he
we had a very good meeting with him last
time it resulted in progress
and uh and the things that he said he
would do were done
and i think it would be very helpful for
the committee yes uh to do that so we're
very appreciative of that is there
enough time however to do a trip well i
think we can always back up if it's not
a difficulty in terms of uh
if it is not a difficulty in terms of
the
flight
uh requirements
i understand but
it seems to me that if departure is 1500
we have to you know see that to do to
average the if you are you want to have
if we were backed up
there's no real difficulty i think in
our arriving in ho chi minh city later
is there no but i'm worried about the
appointment with domoy
can we be back in time for 10 30
meetings
uh 10 30 in the morning yeah that's
roughly tight that is probably difficult
we would have to go we'd have to go
after that meeting to wherever we go
see we can't go on a trip and be back
for a 10 30 meeting with de moy
can we make the meeting with the moy a
little later perhaps if we do the
meeting in the morning i'm gonna do the
trip in the morning
i i don't need to do this uh
well we have the meeting at what eight
o'clock with the home minister
which is important yeah it's important
very important
very important he is helpful in that
area so if we could find a way
it's going to be difficult to fit in
an excursion
you can have somebody to we can go there
and come back yeah some of us can stay
in the technical aspects and the
majority of the group can return here in
time for that meeting no problem if we
get a very start well where would we
chop her from we would go by car
my car
that's the visit to you're talking about
i'm talking about if we went by
helicopter to another location you have
to divide you
if you go by helicopter somebody want to
go and win we'll be out of the meeting
with the
yeah we'll we'll make an arrangement yes
we'll figure it out yeah is this time i
know his time is is is difficult and
we're appreciative of the fact that he's
given us a time that's it is that pretty
uh firm yeah
secretary general yeah okay
and let's work around that yeah guys ask
one clarification uh you said that the
the minute the defense minister would
have to determine whether or not we get
to see the military law division people
is that that's not been set up
that you know
they're responsible for that because the
law division is under theirs you know
but have the names of the people that we
submitted been contacted i mean are they
prepared to be there or are we
um
if possible the people that uh that were
that were listed uh that we submitted on
from the military law division if they
could be
contacted ahead of time
because i don't see how we can find them
that
if they're not right here we're not
we're gonna have difficulty meeting uh
know everything in that area so we
presume that mr e can tell you
everything
you know
but but some of our some of the uh
wmi office people have met with mr e
already we would like to meet with these
still three gentlemen who are the other
because they haven't been met with us
we don't want you
is
oh
[Music]
because if you cannot see you know
one of them asked you
you told me you could have stopped you
know
arranged to see him like
we will is there a way to see him within
the next couple of days while we are
here
even even in the time we're in ho chi
minh city
i i don't know whether you know
i in my mind i arranged for you to seem
to eat that is the one we promised you
know long before no i i understand that
and we appreciate that the problem is
that as we
as a committee are investigating the
issue
certain people say to us
you should talk to
mr you know tom or mr
whatever
and in order to complete our work it's
important for us to be able to see those
people
and that helps
the credibility of the process
and try to communicate with the
department industry you know good
if you could that would be helpful
that's the purpose of this and we
appreciate that
so you know minh city you in
the meeting with the
committee there
you will be meeting with the
mia official working in ho chi minh city
you will be visiting the odp process
you will see some of the
people
with fraudulent remains you know
yes trading correct training involved
and maybe some of the
re-education camp detainees released
already
in ho chi minh city
and then you and then we'll have two
hours two weeks two or three excursions
senator brown will be going to the
dinner
we're not sure where senator grassley
and smith yet but we're deciding that in
the next
i think that sounds very good
if we can do that if we can add these
extra people yeah
that will make a great difference to the
value how about uh
and mr publisher you
tomorrow you have a lot of things to do
later tonight well we can see them later
tonight we could delay our departure
tomorrow we don't have to go yeah
we don't have anything tomorrow evening
when we arrive
i mean we could fly up in hanoi on
excursion here the the thing you did yes
when we just set up and
this is the the the ongoing working you
know
schedule
which then added other than we tried to
reach out
what one of the ambassadors we don't
really have time you don't have time
when was the ambassadors
from this town before we go
where where was the ambassador meeting
going to be
they may come here to see you but
describe it
have they been invited are they in route
no
they
why don't we ask them if they would join
us wherever we're going at the
restaurant that's it
i'd be delighted we could sit with them
and have lunch
i understand that
i would like a couple of colleagues i
remember meeting with them i thought it
was helpful and i think if they could
join us why don't we we'll leave now
we'll go into town for lunch
and uh
and we'll see you at the government
house at two o'clock
[Music]
what i'd like to do is
uh
how
much time you'll have to get around
let's maximize our time we gotta start
to
okay we're on our way
[Music]
huh
yes
[Music]
following the agenda meeting and a brief
lunch the senators made a stop at the
army war museum in hanoi
the war museum houses artifacts and
equipment from the vietnam war including
downed american aircraft
also housed at the museum an archives
room containing war records
the american senators were given
permission to visit the archive room
it's here
i would like them to personally
uh aftermath and i would also like to
see whatever archives are available
today i
[Music]
this is from this is all from what
period this is from the
french the french period yeah
there's american around the back here
right let's go around here
[Music]
it's very happy and honored to have you
here and to meet you in your delegation
today
[Music]
and see please ask
him for anything you want to see now
just tell him and he will help you
we would like to see the
tonkin golf aftermath period and also
archives if they're
to omla for a lot
[Applause]
um
[Music]
he's not having a chance to prepare
something uh along those lines and your
time here is too limited to do that uh
but you can look at to to have him
prepared
i think the things that relate to the
uss turner joy yeah
that's what i want to play turner
uh yeah
any records
[Music]
foreign
on this
yes
[Music]
in cooperation with the mia uh
delegation are you having any problems
and getting materials from them
there is a lot more information we'd
like to have but we're not sure exactly
what they have here
but we're not sure
um
he's ready to continue to work on this
we would like to just show us where
um
um
okay i just said you want to go to the
place don't have them bring you the
documents just go
you want to do it now right so do we
have time right there
where is it
here
they have to understand
them yes it's here can we know what
they're doing
uh
um
all the stuff in the prisoners is back
in this room
look at this the mig 21 9
14 euros
oh
the propeller no no this is the old a1
skyraider
isn't it rotary
i'm sure yeah
we didn't have any of those in in
we used them for the uh they were used
for in close combat
i didn't know
the u.s plan for the war
that they put was put the supply base
here
and supply and interdiction of the
hotend and trail in through here
and they put in the supply base
and then never went in with the
interdiction
yeah but
there's a carrier but it was all set up
for it that's what you were looking for
it never did
there was something over there
in english that said this was
it somehow uh in effect would have
confirmed the
uh offensive action that was always in
question with respect to it take a look
at that map all the way over in the
corner that might be the way it's not in
you're my english
[Music]
i'm looking for the period for
the queen tree and denying and uh are
over here
it doesn't show much of it
what you're looking for because it's uh
their forces
no
some place there was a uh
on the gulf
that had to do with the gulf incident
well let's see
this is the rest reference to kwang nom
near denying but it's uh you can't
recognize right now
there was something that related
specifically to the
incident where he said he's got a room
back here from 1964. okay
dedicated to 64.
[Music]
[Music]
westmoreland
the second one on the other side we
haven't been able to tell if he's an
american or vietnamese this guy here is
in america this one's still missing yes
sir what the date on this was when
uh i'd have to look at our files i think
it's 1965 case
yeah
noah
uh
hey he opened the door for you he's got
the key very good
let's go ahead he opened the door same
picture
that's the same picture we found in
moscow right here that picture
isn't that amazing who is that right
there that looks like uh
[Music]
[Music]
separated at birth
thank you very much
[Applause]
we don't have a lot of time
they unlock the room over here
andre what's this here
this tower
um
bill have you ever been in up here
[Music]
did he say yes
the answer is
they run the flag up there on special
occasions
um
surprising isn't open all the time
[Music]
this is the workplace and here you have
a picture
[Music]
has gone over these very very carefully
because you know they have them uh
arranged in order these are all of the
pictures of pows or what
these are general histories of the
vietnamese war
but they have interspersed in them
uh pictures of uh
of uh
from the war these are named my
campaigns like the ho chi minh campaign
where would the history where would the
prison system records speak to a bach
he said those do not come under him he
said because you know what he's
responsible for is the collection
of the vietnam's the history of
vietnamese armed conflicts with the
french the japanese the americans etc
who did the prison record
yeah
you could more usefully put to some of
your other interlocutors from other
vietnamese agencies he said because he
really has just the mission of
the uh assembling these war records in
and who gave him these war records where
did they come
were contributed by the different
military units in the um
central vietnam south vietnam north
vietnam the different parts of the
country could we look at one just while
we're talking just for bill have you
been through these where's bill
cool
yes
easy
now here's august 1955.
okay that's a difference where's where's
1960s
[Music]
1973
this is a participation from the
villagers in mehing village
yes
and participating in the resistance ward
[Music]
foreign
that photographs in to include in the in
the histories
here
the thing is he knows that it's
frustrating to you because you don't he
doesn't have everything collected here
that bears directly on mia he's afraid
maybe no no he does and well he said
that they they've tried with with bob
just and everything they've assembled
things that you know he can he looks
through these things and he picks out
what's adventurous to him but he said
that he probably you know it's going to
take probably extended effort to contact
veterans from are there other places
where there are records
of the war
vietnamese
[Music]
you're if you're confident senator about
narrative histories longer narrative
histories that that's more directly
under the department of defense and
probably the department of defense has
more of the narrative histories as
opposed to the sort of pictorial uh
presentation but as the curator where
would he go to find information about
prisoners of war
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh he goes to veterans and the veterans
organization
he goes yeah
come
to make this uh
these exhibits and the the
information here as helpful as possible
to your efforts and as constructive and
effort as possible to help build a
better relationship between our two
countries
c-span's coverage of the senate pow mia
affairs committee april trip to vietnam
continues
coming next a meeting with the general
secretary of the communist party domoy
it was during this meeting in april that
the senators pressed for and were given
permission to visit unannounced any
prison in the country in their search
for information on american pows and
missing in
action morning
[Music]
here
how are you
[Music]
don't mean
uh
um
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
i have to get the american people to
give us a raise so i can afford to bring
them
[Music]
in my mind
uh
the salary of my prime minister is only
fifty dollars a month fifty dollars
what
[Music]
well i wanted to
i wanted to ask you
senator smith all the centers um
how
do you have an idea of what how much
time it might take for your committee to
determine whether the vietnamese are
providing full cooperation or as much
cooperation as they could we personally
think it can be done in a matter of
months and
we had that conversation with the
general secretary he asked us point
blank
what do we need to do to resolve this
issue
he said we'll do anything
we need to do to resolve this issue
so we laid out to him those things that
we believe will assist in resolving this
issue the bottom line of which is
to be able to show the american people a
good faith effort
that proves to the best of our ability
that there's no live american being held
in vietnam
now there are ways to do that
access to the countryside
and we talked about these access to the
records
the archives to military and unit
documents hospitals prisons
access to personnel
people who can assist us in answering
questions
about the so-called discrepancy cases
those people last known to be alive
and i'm quite confident and other
senators will speak for themselves but i
think there's a consensus
that the committee in a few months ought
to be able to look at this process and
know
through general needham bill bell
colonel donovan whether or not there is
cooperation
whether or not barriers are being put up
i think all of us leave here
very encouraged
that the general secretary has made a
firm commitment
that the government and the people are
prepared to cooperate and that we ought
to be able to resolve this issue and at
the lower levels of government to both
governments it'll make each of
their jobs easier because of the clear
signal that he sent in this
room
at this meeting that he expected or that
he was going to have his government
fully cooperate what we have here today
is a clear breakthrough in the
relationship
it's a solid commitment
to give us access to following up on the
live citing reports and to verify once
and for all that there are no americans
being held captive and i think this is a
turnaround point at this
uh today it marks a turnaround point in
our relationships
and i think
we can look forward to a quick
assessment as to whether indeed anyone
is being held i'd like to support that
because i have been i traveled here in
1986 and met with the vietnamese leaders
i traveled here in 1988 as a member of
congress and met with the vietnamese
leaders i'm here this year and i've
never heard any
statement any stronger more direct more
honest more open
than the one today from the the general
secretary he flat out gave a commitment
that he will provide us the access that
we need to resolve this and i i think he
means it and we're going to
we're going to follow up on it
immediately and the facilities to
provide that exercise did you tell you
to discuss the helicopter we discussed
it uh
we discussed the logistics to a degree
i'm going to be taking that up more
specifically with the foreign secretary
i did discuss it this morning with the
interior department and
our sense is that
the details that remain to be worked out
can be worked out the live citing
reports that that we still have that are
that are unresolved he has promised us
access to resolve it one way or the
other in addition to that
we discussed the possibility if laos
agrees
to having vietnam agree
to have access to laos and egress from
laos through vietnam on those issues
that has been agreed to
providing of course laos agrees to our
going into those areas and so
there's an additional capacity to follow
up on laos but the most important piece
with respect to vietnam is
is a determination to try to
permit this easy access so we're going
to put it to the test
this afternoon
we've asked for a person from the
ministry of the interior to be assigned
to us they're going to meet us at lunch
they do not know where we're going to
ask to go at this point in time and
we're going to ask to go somewhere and
see if we can get in and it's a place
we've been denied access to previously
so we'll see where we wind up
mind if we follow you
uh no that's uh i can't tell you where
we're going but you don't follow and
follow
well that's a big change in attitude and
then the feelings that you all had
yesterday when it looked like you're
being stonewalled and stalemated and
nothing was really being well i didn't
express that maybe a few colleagues felt
it on the base of the means i thought
yesterday was a preview to today
and in fact the general secretary said
that he received a full briefing on
everything that we did yesterday and was
prepared to follow up on it if i could
just make an additional comment on that
because i think that the significance
and perhaps the reason why things are
changing a little bit here now
is that senator kerry made it very clear
that this committee was formed
with a sunset at the end of this year to
resolve this issue period and that we
need their help to do it as well as our
own government we're investigating uh
all of the background of our own
government and we also need their help
and and we made it very clear that uh
that will open the door for for the
normalization process to begin and i
think they understand that now whereas
before every time somebody comes over
from the state department or wherever it
seems like it's an ongoing process it
has it's always had a it's just doesn't
have an end to it this has an end to it
and and uh and i think now that that
that message has gotten through i think
that's why uh things are changing we
made it very clear to the general
secretary as a group
uh that this is an opportunity
this committee has one
charge
to find the truth
we're a bipartisan committee six
democrats six republicans it's not
ideological and it has not been partisan
in any regard
and the only goal is to answer the
questions outstanding
are there live americans in vietnam
today
and what can we say about the history of
this that leads us to draw a conclusion
about that issue and every one of those
reports that we have are going to be
investigated directly on site according
to the commitment we receive today
that's what we're going to start doing
so i think there's a huge amount of work
to be done in the next three to four
months but in that period of time
if general needham and others can report
back to us that
they're covering the countryside they're
getting cooperation things are happening
i think the committee is going to be in
a position
to make some major
statements about where we're going here
all right you guys can see this is
something
no spain
i thought it went well
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i was holding
i
um
[Music]
there's
how long has he been the director
um
um
[Music]
huh
we have nice big
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
some of his predecessors have retired
and some of them died
um
uh i've been here since 1967. uh
long before you are interested in this
prisoners
how many places for prisoners do you
have
they important
this can house many people
do you remember
in the 1970s were there ever any
americans
held here
[Music]
[Music]
were there any american pows here pilots
before 1976
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
but of course i can show you around
especially to the place where uh the new
american people was held
back
oh
foreign
i don't think you are allowed to take
pictures or feel where is the
administrative interior person
[Applause]
i thought we were going to be able to
just walk around
but these two men are responsible for
this camp so we have to do what they
want to do and they are moi and yeah
some of the people
are still out there are just people who
are investigating so i'm not about to
approach it oh i understand
um
[Music]
any danger
[Music]
we should have had the general secretary
along with us well the question was
whether or not they said they never had
any americans care
in the war time and now they are saying
they did have some here during the war
[Music]
yeah i think so
that's the only thing
i guess
yep
it's around this area
what's around this area
um
is
[Music]
if you don't
everybody here is going to believe there
is somebody in there
and and
mr khan and your general secretary said
you must get on the phone and call
and let these people see
even if it's just the senators and no
press
if you don't solve it it's going to be
there okay you understand yeah
they've got two
captains here that get two diaries right
company would be a couple hundred people
each one
so major is uh
i think he's just two or three companies
i think he's just coming out of the
president
as the facility is not basically any
size
[Music]
i wonder where they can rank
yes
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
to leave and the no cameras for now okay
well they can they just wait here
um
yeah yeah the the press can wait here
well they take the senators
okay so that we'll leave the press here
and we'll come through here give it uh
just like our staff
print they sent
[Music]
cameras will probably be safe here
okay let's respect the rules now no no
fixes
[Music]
they're very protective here
they still let us in to see lots of
portions of it
the portion they looked at is one that
did hold american prisoners
who were later transferred to the hanoi
hilton so it uh
it's the unit that's been used in the
past
and it apparently is also a unit our
people tried to see uh
earlier this month and were denied
access to
for the conditions like starter just
want yourself is it still in use uh
there isn't any us prison that would uh
it would get approved by any state in
this condition but for this part of the
world it's
not unexpected
there's one cell occupied
by two people
in for two it would be fairly cramped
but
i think the more interesting cells
appear to be the ones over here that
are like
metal boxes
that we haven't had a chance to see yet
this is a very good thing for us to do
today because it uh
it's a check to see if the general
secretaries
commitment is going to be followed
is this what what you've had to go
through to get into where you wanted to
go do you feel that's meeting up to what
the general secretary promised well
clearly not yet but we haven't heard
back from higher authorities yet
it's clear
there's still in many ways a closed
society and it's uh
a difficult transition for him
although
it is ironic this is the first time i've
ever tried to break in jail
i never expected to have a problem
i always thought the problem was getting
out do you think that you think that
do you think they were surprised
i mean the indications were the bottles
of water sent out there that this was no
surprise
uh i don't know i don't know uh yes
there are rumors that someone knew in
advance but i don't know what the facts
are you think it it
was an educated guess on their part
since you came here
since americans came here earlier this
month with denying access that
just an educated guess would tell them
this is where you wanted to come
i don't know
my impression was there were other
potential sites
south of the city
um
there would be others you know more more
informed than i on that but my
impression is that there are a number of
sites in the hanoi area where we've had
reports
so that
when was the decision made that this was
going to be the place
let me defer that to senator kerry
what'll be happening in the next two
months
it's obviously not an easy transition
for the vietnamese
and it's obviously essential for
americans to have confidence
that there are not americans being held
there's not a whole lot there except for
the fact that we get in to this place
some major breakthrough to test
whether the system's working and
obviously
getting this far is further than
anybody would have gotten before yeah
are you a little disappointed though
that you didn't get as far as maybe you
thought you might well yeah but we
aren't done yet they're making a call to
the foreign minister
and hopefully having him intervene and
then the five senators can go in
congress
senator brown said that this place would
[Music]
the civil liberties union would have uh
have the state and the municipality in
the county and
in jail and with a big tort liability
now at lunch i talked with the foreign
minister about problems that do arise in
terms of the interpretation
of instructions and there are people at
lower levels who don't always
hear what they're being told or don't
want to or various other things
and change comes slowly in different
quarters i think that's true anywhere
but i'm convinced that the foreign
minister the minister of interior the
defense minister
and domoy
want us
to be able to have this kind of access
and i'm convinced it will happen there
is a problem
again without divulging the sources give
me an idea of what you knew about this
place ahead of time that made you want
to come here well we knew that this was
an active prison uh we knew that it was
a president of the uh ministry of the
interior a central prison of the
srv government
we had reports indicating that americans
were held in this area during the war
and also some commandos were held here
in the early 60s
we have also received reports
indicating that some foreigners were
held here after operation homecoming the
american pws that we believe that were
held here
until operation homecoming were actually
captured in south vietnam and moved here
but released in 1973
they were never moved into the hanoi
prison system that we know of
and at the time of their release in 1973
they were taken from this prison and
moved to xialam airport where they were
released by the provisional
revolutionary government
the sketches can you tell me where the
sketch came from or give me an idea of
was that a key piece of
the intelligence for this place well the
sketches are always important because
they can verify whether or not it's the
same specific facility that the
individual has reported to us and in
this case the sketches are almost
exactly
they almost exactly match the outlay of
the prison
interior your intelligence indicated
that there had been americans held here
when you asked that question upstairs
with the
prison major did you already know the
answer to it before you asked it was
that part of the test
no this was not a test
we didn't ask that question the senate
select committee did
the reply that they received was based
on
their opinion that they were inquiring
about prisoners that were held after the
war and the prisoners that we knew are
fairly certain that were held here were
held here before operation homecoming up
until operation homecoming
the senators are very pleased that that
this has all come about you've been
working on this project for years now
is it a relief to finally be able to
have access to places like this
we have been granted access to presence
before but only at the province level
and to my knowledge this is the first
time that we've
been allowed into a prison of the
central government so this is progress
as far as you're concerned i think if
the senate select committee was not here
and if they didn't make a request at the
very highest levels of the vietnamese
government i doubt if we would be
allowed access into this prison do you
think the access will continue after the
senator's leave
i hope so
we're very
optimistic on that point
c-span's coverage of the senate p-o-w
mia affairs committee's april trip to
vietnam continues
just ahead we join senator john kerry of
massachusetts and senator bob smith of
new hampshire on the tarmac of saigon's
tonsinet airport as they prepare for a
full day of travel in the mekong delta
translating for the senators is andre
savagio
[Music]
foreign
you want to go today uh everything is
all right the only problem is time let's
go let's go
home
no senator
[Music]
so
so
we should be back here about five times
we'll do the best we can
[Music]
no i
[Music]
well the entrance here where the road
comes in is right over in here
who came up to that last year the fact
there's a snake farm over here
that's what at the snake farm that's
what the guy told us
that there was a snake from there yeah i
know exactly where it is
[Music]
uh roadside farm right at the that's
right
yeah that's what we want
that's the uh where we go out there was
it a french style gate yeah that's
wrought iron it's a gate to the base
it's a big
it's the big entrance to the base it's
the main entrance to the base
so
[Music]
entrance
all right
uh
committee uh responsible for the
accounting for america's missing action
smith
together
foreign
years ago i was right here
technique
i said navy yeah
have any of them uh ask if any of them
have had contact
with former american soldiers in any of
the last years
uh
uh
we hope our countries
who's the commander
[Music]
uh
it's very fine thank you thank you for
receiving us
he's lieutenant
okay
[Music]
this is okay this is fine but he just
didn't know you know where we were he
didn't know where we were
well thank you how long has he been in
the army
from 1965 was he uh was he fighting in
this region
i mean
at first he was not here he was in the
east
and then later on
city operation yeah
when
zhang city johnson city youngston city
operation
was he in the uh was he regular or was
he
was the
main
[Music]
um
uh
uh no senator not not americans there
have been a number of delegations that
have come in he remembers a number of
soviet delegations that have been in
here and other foreigners but not
americans during the war what did you do
with the prisoners that they captured
um
[Music]
um
well during the war if they captured the
american who was uh injured or something
then the first party would be to you
know dress the wounds and take care of
the of the wounds but if they were
if they were healthy then they would be
processed to the back transfer to the
back area yeah
did they keep a record of the person
that they captured
[Music]
the combat they didn't have the
opportunity to do that things were
moving too much in combat yeah
so they just move them forward
commanders just have to they have to
rely on their superiors to do that as
they process them up to the chain
andre can we borrow two bites and go
around here
omaha
is there any type of detention
[Music]
they don't have a detention uh authority
here because they only have a military
mission so there's no no prisoners no
kind ever
no uh i mean
um
because it has to be it has to be under
a different authority and uh done you
know in their legal system
so he has never had any americans
pows or even uh drug smugglers of any
americans of any kind
right down the road
do you know where the snake farm is
there's a snake
right
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
uh
um
um
if it's too difficult
we can walk over yeah
what was here what american basis huge
base 9th infantry division and the
marine river rainforest was based right
out here
you had thousands i think something like
30 000 people one of my guys got wounded
we actually came in here to the hospital
and they had a tremendous
medevac
facility
on-site operation
a lot of folks this whole delta area was
just you know the minute you get up in
the air you still see some scars of it
are there any
barracks left around here that you saw
sure there but they're very few it's
interesting there was a huge i mean px
there was a you know the mars station
there was just an extraordinary amount
of stuff here a lot of areas burned out
down there a lot of stuff has just been
destroyed what are you looking for
around this area
well we've never
ever had access to this area i was
actually turned away from here a year
ago
but that was without any effort to set
it up
but our people have never been able to
come in here this is a first time event
and
we've been particularly interested to
put the process to test with this new
cooperation to see
how how capable they are really changing
standard behavior of 20 years
and i mean this is very very successful
this is rather extraordinary i mean we
come in here they weren't expecting us
to land here these guys come out
spontaneously and give us an amazing
response i mean it's a very
i mean i think it's a story in itself
really in many ways yeah are these
regular military now here in vietnam
yeah these guys are the uh they're
called
they are the regular military forces of
vietnam what's interesting is the
colonel was in charge of the base
and i was fighting from 1965 to 1975.
it's been here since 78 but uh
you know they're uh
they're the guys
do you have any personal uh reaction to
coming back to where
you know if i stop and really reflect
i'm sure i'll have more we're on
business so i'm kind of moving through
it but
it's meaningful how long were you in
this area very short time because we
were patrolling we were all through the
delta rivers and
most of this area
was from a command that i only spent
about a month with
based over in the vung tau area and we'd
come at it from there
and then i was shifted over the southern
area and we were in most of the southern
part of the delta after that but we saw
most of the rivers and canals through
this whole region i mean through most of
the delta expect to find anything
specific
related to the p.o.w
no we don't come here with us
there isn't i think a capacity to find
quote something specific everything is
cumulative
and everything is subjective in many
ways it's really circumstantial that you
build as a as a conglomerate
uh you know i want to emphasize that
nobody here is out here
with the assumption and you're going to
stumble across some revelations but what
we're trying to do is
check spontaneity and find out
through increased access
what the probabilities are and you begin
to deal with probabilities as much as
anything when you have a spontaneous
reaction from a young group of troops
who who live in the region all of whom
kind of say well gee
you know i've never seen anybody except
a tourist
it begins to become part of the
cumulative picture and i think what
we're really trying to do today is not
you know accomplish some extraordinary
revelational
single person
oriented mission what we're trying to do
is test whether or not our teams are
going to be able to get the access how
open the vietnamese are really prepared
to be under this new regime
and whether or not we can put this issue
as a whole to rest by opening the door
for our teams over the next few months
to really scour the countryside and
answer the questions that exist and this
has been a good test so far today
senator smith you have a vietnam veteran
up there on that hat where were you
well i was uh i was at sea i was down in
the mekong area for a while and up uh up
off station and yankee station between
henan island and uh and the coast so uh
i wasn't on on shore but saw a lot of
action uh
in the uh during the the rage you know
the aircraft that flew from the carriers
in we refueled them and
spent about uh eight or nine months out
here on station so it's a it's a uh it's
a weird feeling to be back this is my
third trip back
but i have i didn't go to the south the
first two times that i came here in 86
and 88 we were only in hanoi so this is
my first time back to this region it's a
it's a strange feeling in many ways and
mixed emotions
about it should other vietnam veterans
try to get back and do this
i think i think it'd be good for a lot
of them i think uh
having the experience uh uh in a
different environment obviously is
healthy
uh i think senator kerry and i feel that
way and i think others do as well what
years were you here
we need to go
what i was here uh
1966 and part of 67.
i think we need to roll because the
refuel time and
my sense is
if you want to go out to the snake farm
area i'm game but i think we gotta roll
if we're gonna do it you wanna do it how
do you wanna do it can we walk there can
we think we can use this car
what about this how many kilometers
available to us
how many kilometers
and that's what a mile or close to it
that's a little a little more huh it's a
little more
one that's five miles
maybe we could fly over it
that's not gonna do anything good here
and we want to go to the other side
we're basically on the wrong side of the
base and we're right here and we need to
go over to this entrance right now
that's right
there was nothing around that
i was right there about we could see it
there was nothing there
it's all grown up i mean we didn't we
were just there because we came into the
entrance but it was all grown up
there's nothing there
but you didn't get in though
it you know it's a question of
permissions
[Music]
i mean this is more critical than hattie
and we can draw patients can we will
they let us land over there by the
entrance where's uh where's
andre
thank you
[Music]
um
he'd be glad to do more things for you
oh i very much appreciate that we will
have some people who will
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're getting an incredible uh review
of
some of the wonders of our
creation here that have been left behind
and are really in a state of disarray
i don't know
i didn't know a lot about this man i
never got here
formally to the base i got out of the
river but this
i think was a big uh helicopter squadron
where the cope was flew out of
everything and i think all these things
over here are what are the old cobra
senator question yes do you want to go
into the city here or go
um just time wise
if it's half an hour it takes it takes a
half an hour to refuel you mean yeah
commander
uh
uh two way
how long does it take to refuel
the uh dozo
oh
hi my name
20 from 20 to 30 minutes well let's only
go for 20 minutes
[Music]
but this was a lot of chopper to get out
of here your attack yeah
[Music]
thank you so much nice to see you nice
to see you good morning
good morning
we're glad to see you thank you for
meeting us
do they use any of the buildings
[Music]
what will they
[Music]
they are now waiting to get some
response
from the
council of ministers in hanoi as to what
to do with us
[Music]
uh uh understands this is a good runway
however he would like to have one even
better
okay
they're gonna try to fuel fast
yes
[Music]
[Music]
will you join us
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the local authorities have invited you
to go into a hotel and to be there for
10 minutes only
uh
but they have invited you to that can
you do that
we can do that
i'm not a party dog new man
i'm not about
[Music]
[Music]
tell me
what uh what do you do on the remains
how do you collect remains
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
they haven't had actually they found
haven't found any remains in his area
however they did have one case where
there was a american re reported died
here in that you know and then uh
two years ago in america and uh yes so
they no longer the operation yeah
yeah they got the information two years
ago yeah
the american who died when
uh during the war
but he said the thing is
they they had the you know organized the
uh
uh inquiry along the lines that they
described to you with the participation
of the ministry of uh defense
and um
an interior but that the time period had
been too long and the
you know the marines
were washed away has he ever
asked him if he's ever seen or heard
seen any americans or heard of any
americans
[Music]
since uh
since the war
is
[Music]
they've never had any information about
live americans in this area
no no prisoners no deserters
now
[Music]
nothing not not even people staying here
to get married senator
what
what is the
what is the level of people trying to
bring remains in
and claim that they are americans
maybe they had instances
of um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
but they don't have uh anybody try to do
that there was
there was an american uh in the mid 70s
who came back
to look for his vietnamese wife
in the mid 70s
after the war
yes after the war
[Music]
hey
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you sent his remains home listen let
me show you
he died he was here in prison in this
area may to september of 1975.
he was he let me say he's not in p.o.w
okay but he died and his remains were
returned
and somebody should know where he was in
prison that's what we're trying to do
right now okay
so
[Music]
[Music]
he doesn't know who would know where
that person was in prison
we can ask the interior ministry and get
the answer
party
[Music]
14 years sir
we should ask people to community when
we get to the hotel see if we want their
nose
we're going to run into time uh turn
around there
this is not just 10 minutes
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
down there
[Music]
the political part of it is this they
waited long they were ran earlier
waiting earlier
but they have but they've been told as a
compromise thing that they would you
would be with them for just a few
minutes and they would really be
offended if
but he emphasized that you don't have
time
so they expect that they're
psychologically prepared for a very
short encounter but i'm not
psychologically prepared to not meet
when does the encounter but i'm i'm
worried
are there other places like the same
that we might not go to yes there are
you said that there are but perhaps you
can call and tell them there's a problem
[Music]
m
[Music]
is
[Music]
come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
we need
[Music]
no no we don't have time
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
right here
[Music]
which is
[Music]
but that could take us
[Music]
i think i think more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think in the long run
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i think we have time to if we
[Music]
i understand
um
waiting in another location too but that
they're going to arrange with them to
cancel that
no hard feelings
would you express my apologies
come
because he looks at the uh
close cooperation
with you
and your uh delegation has been their
responsibility
furthermore they're not going to engage
you in any long program here because he
knows you don't have time
he's a very sensitive man
i wish i wish everybody in political
life was a savvy to uh
tell us if you would please
about the pow mia issue here how you
think about it and how you handle it
uh
foreign
[Music]
in the beginning in 1985 they organized
the uh
uh subcommittee on the uh uh m.i.a
accounting uh in this area
and the uh chairman of that subcommittee
is the
is the uh deputy
yeah
vice chairman of the people's committee
the people's committee
[Music]
structure is the kernel
uh who commands
it
is the military commander uh
of the in this uh area
oh
uh
has been only organized one month ago
and what do they do
on powma how do they try to help
[Music]
um
the first thing is that they widely
disseminate the information among their
own people that the governments of uh
united states and the socialist republic
of vietnam have an agreement with each
other to try to account for america's
missing in action
this is an essential first step because
only if they are aware of this agreement
and the importance of the two
governments attached to it then they
will be
ready uh they'll be prepared to look for
information
how do they put that information out to
people uh uh
where
so they have uh groups that actually go
out to the uh different areas and spread
it by word of mouth
[Music]
about some american in a uh area that
was a combat zone or something uh was uh
involved or lost in an area then they
will send people out to investigate
those reports what kind of reports do
they get of an american visa
um
they have not actually received any
reports here about an american missing
uh being alive here but what they have
done
but there have been reports about
remains
uh is it possible
is it possible in his opinion for any
american to be living anywhere in the
delta area
[Music]
he had the impression that when you
asked
for him to speculate about the whole
area
that uh there just are no americans
living under any auspices or any
circumstances in the whole area and he
said he particularly feels more strongly
that way now because since he's been
involved for the five months here on
this job
and has been paying a lot of attention
to this issue in his own area and
looking at the whole situation more
intensively
then he just reasons out from that that
it's very unlikely that anybody could be
living uh in any place in the delta area
um lower delta or upper delta or any
place uh
without anybody knowing about it in your
uh conversations with um
with others in your in in the government
do you
and and in vietnam have you
uh ever heard anyone
discuss a living american anywhere in
vietnam
[Music]
he's heard lots of conversations about
remains
none not one about a living america
um
at the end of the week where were you
during the war
in 1968 69 i was not here
was he was he fighting is he part of the
military effort
well he said like so many people he
began in heaven in uh when he was about
20 years old for him that makes it about
1950
scooped up the people from very early
age
well was there any time in 1975
and right after 1975
that he knew of some americans still
alive here who have died since then
from 75. in 1975 when the war ended
where some people still here and then
they died
[Music]
foreign
he never had heard any report like that
that you asked about
the only exception being
that uh jim coyle from the joint
casualty resolution center department of
defense joint casualty resolution center
in bangkok came here and said to him
ask him about some information about a
person who's missing and jim said that
they had somebody information
and they gave him the coordinate
where they had the information
and that he just said he remembers the
name of the person that jim coyle
and who was believed to have died in
captivity
[Music]
to the united states in 1973
by the provisional revolutionary
government of uh south vietnam
let me ask you one one last question
before we have
[Music]
my last question to you is this
some people in the united states are
convinced
that there are some people being held
here
good night still alive
how do we resolve this issue between our
two countries how do we answer these
doubts
foreign
because he thinks it's such a strange
thing for people to think that
is that's a strange idea
um
so he's been in this area since the end
of the war
what why is it strange
when many frenchmen
after diane benfu in 1954
um
his surprise senator smith sir his
surprise
uh reaction and the reason he thinks
it's a strange idea is based on his
experience in this area where because he
has so much experience in this area
because he's never heard of any such
report because he's so familiar with
this area he knows there can no be there
could not be any such
uh event in this area therefore
taking from his limited experience and
expanding it psychology reacts in a very
surprised way can you finish the answer
to my question of how we resolve the
issue
how do we get rid of the doubts
they swap small ball
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
he said that he believes that the answer
to your question how to
to um
resolve this issue and get rid of the
suspicions and the conviction that that
the vietnamese are still holding
prisoners that the way to solve that is
very close cooperation between our sides
now on this issue
basically
he said that he said
there is
yeah okay that's fine he said he said
that he would be willing to hurt
him
baby
he's ready to invite more and more
americans coming here
let me let me just say that we would we
appreciate that and we would like to
take you up on that because we have
people
aren't our technical people who would
like to come into this region and meet
with you and and your people to to final
to try to make some determinants
uh
people people in our country need to
know
that this cooperation is happening
and our visit our ability to be able to
go to the places that we have asked to
go
is a very important way of saying to
americans that vietnam is open and
cooperating
[Music]
in the next few months
as our people come here
to follow up on the questions that our
committee has
if those questions are answered
we can resolve
and we don't believe the black clouds
can stay over our head for too long at a
time
and especially if we continue our
cooperation
thank you very much here's to clear
skies
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
marston mapping
[Music]
was this all american this whole base uh
there was some vietnamese here too
yeah
we used to doc that was our doctorate
over there
we come in here overnight
or get a couple days if our boats needed
repair we had a repair thing out there
that was floating they'd lift the boat
right out put it on the
repair the hock and fix it up and
put a barracks shut that down where
would you operate two from here which
way would you oh we go straight back
into the whole peninsula we go back
about a half an hour over to 10
and go up there and then we go way down
the end of the peninsula and work off we
had destroyers and uh
coast guard vessels re-harm us and
everything but we go into the rivers and
spend about a week
you call the brown water navy
yeah
well it became known as that river rats
i don't know
but not when we were out here when we
were out here with turquoise and
paradise it was beautiful look at this
stuff
this belongs to vietnam this part oh
yeah this is uh we have 15 000 prisoners
of war right up here in the south
and um
this is where they make a great fish
sauce
no no but this is uh the reason we came
here today is that uh
our guys really wanted to talk to the
security people here a number of
americans have been arrested
in the waters here off of yachts and
other things some involved in narcotics
muggling other kinds of things and
our guys really wanted to get a handle
on how many and who had been
worked into their prison system
etc in order to be able to determine
in order to determine
um
who uh who might be the subject of a
live-sighting report or something
well putting people into the system
means that we can if there are prisoners
in there these guys that went in with
the yachts and so forth we can track
them
what we really want to push for is
records of bournemouth
okay no cameras no cameras no cameras
[Music]
he's explained everything that you're
doing what you've done that you saw muay
you've been in hanoi for a couple days
he's explained everything they've
received no information here the local
commander said of course they want to do
anything that they're allowed to do for
you but he's trying to find out what
that is and how they can find out that's
good i'm glad they didn't know uh tell
them that's good that's exactly the
point
uh andre
andre we need to find the key security
people for time to speak to
the security people that tom needs to
talk to is the whole purpose of being a
tom yes who do you need
what's the rationale you want to talk to
foreign whoever's in charge i would like
to
i would like to get records for all
foreigners captured or find out who has
the handle on that so he can come back
here at the appropriate time and get
that make sure he get permission to come
back here andre that's what we want
foreign
[Music]
again
a lot of a lot of americans uh who
we have tracked as people uh
you know for example people dealing in
drugs and so forth who have been
captured
put into the prison system here they
apparently from what our information
tells us have a number of very elaborate
records
and that when people go into the system
here they go right they can they can be
tracked all the way up through the
prison facilities to hanoi in other
words a series of stop-off points
detention centers all the way up
and the idea and they have it we think
they have a very based on our
intelligence they have a very elaborate
record-keeping system so if we can if we
can
get access to that and and break the
break the ice here which is really
see they have not our people on the
ground over in bangkok have not had
access to this stuff
and they have not given access through
the
through the executive branch
uh with their with whatever they've
tried to do so here with the senate
committee we've explained to du moy
that that this is that this committee is
trying to conclude this issue and that
if he will cooperate with us we can
conclude if we can get access to the
records and documents that we want
so
this is this is an important
area although we don't have any specific
live sighting reports here
it is the beginning process of the
uh you know of the prison system there
have been americans in it who were not
pows
and that's where that's where it started
so if we that's where this a lot of them
started right here so if we can get
those records
we then can verify
or seek the names of people who were in
these who allege
live sighting reports all the way up the
prison line up for the detention
facilities from here all the way to
hanoi
and they have a very elaborate system
that you know for example the one that
we went in the other day
is one of them
and
we're going to try to drop in on another
one on the way back which we haven't
told them about yet very
a very good one
are you surprised that uh almost
everywhere we've stopped they except i
guess kanto they haven't really
been expecting you well that's the point
i mean that's why i think i don't think
their communications are that good to
begin with and i think that uh
this is exactly what we wanted to
accomplish
we uh we're trying to
use the spontaneity uh when we were
for example
in the first stop
that we made we literally sat down on
the edge of one of their major
military facilities
so
we we had access spontaneous access to a
couple of hundred
troops
with their commander who really did not
know we were going to land there they
knew we were coming into the vicinity
but they didn't know where we were going
to land
so when we throw a question out there
like
who uh
have you seen any live americans
and they all say no at one time watch
you
that gives you a pretty good indication
um
that kind of spontaneity is the kind of
thing we want and then after that we
then take that we then take
the follow-up with our guys and have
them come
back here
meet with these guys go over records
and and get keep the process working so
that we can track down these live
sighting reports
and and try to determine you know just
how much validity there is to them i
wonder if you're at all envious that
this is where senator kerry was uh for
his duty
well uh
it's a it's a very uh
it's a little difficult for me i've been
as we were flying over i
i was uh
i was really
struck by looking down at at the whole
mekong delta where we flew in
i was struck by the fact that a lot of
people died down in there it uh
in fact i've been thinking about that
all day about how many people have died
around here but no this is a i'm sure
this is very emotional for senator kerry
because he was stationed here
um but i was uh i was right off of here
we were in uh we were out in the in the
sea of thailand
uh gulf of thailand uh we were out we we
ran in there we were also in
around on the yankee station around
up in the northern part of the along off
of the north off of north vietnam as
well because i was on a tanker so we
were we went all over the place so
although i never touched my feet here
we were
we were in the vicinity
they have no cameras
and they asked to return to the area and
they've got some more information i've
got to go tell them the same thing
[Music]
how warm that water
[Music]
but it's a you know it is it's difficult
i mean you know to come back you've been
here and you know a lot of people died
and and it's a place where you've been
and but you know it's uh the main
purpose is not to reminisce or to come
back and
be in a place where you're where you
serve the main purpose is to try to
account for people that are missing
that's what we're trying to do do you
think that or maybe i want to ask your
leading question but has america gotten
over vietnam
no it hasn't uh there were a lot of
things that were done wrong let's face
it
uh it hasn't i hope that we can uh the
main the main thing uh if we're ever
gonna heal the wounds we're going to
have to we're going to have to
at least be satisfied that we've
accounted for everybody that we can
account for
and i that's our goal here that's the
goal of the committee and uh we the the
significance of this is we we are now
we're now having we're setting foot
we're having access to places that were
before restricted entirely
uh americans just are not allowed to
come in helicopters and land here
uh so and our guys have been trying for
years to get in here and stand to do
this so we think by getting here now
even if we don't see documents today
we're here now and i think because of
that we'll be able to have the follow-up
of our guys coming back
water is very warm
very well must be 85
number one choice yeah number one choice
go to rockjaw
[Music]
okay
can we land
there is no place for landing no we can
land on the original airport
and then we could get a ride yes right
here how far is that nine kilometers
at 90 kilometers 90 kilometers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes he just said yeah
[Music]
we'll ask somebody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me talk to tom and bob
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
will the people be very upset
[Music]
um
[Music]
they contacted last night for your
mission they are the ones who will have
waited longest
[Music]
they were so enthusiastic they said they
wait for you from five in the morning
but he said no not have to wait so early
but a little bit later but he thinks in
practical terms they have waited all day
[Music]
senator he said they probably at first
they were
uh so enthusiastic they said they wait
for you from five in the morning but he
said no not have to wait so early but a
little bit later but he thinks in
practical terms they have waited all day
[Music]
and if you're going and if you're going
to hatia if you go to hattie not only
will you meet them after they raiders
along but they are the kinzang province
organization with the responsibility for
zekza so you're getting both with one
stone plus you get the permission for
the people to follow up with future
trips too
many more
[Music]
give me that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where's andre
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
um
then it's okay for them to call the
people back right
um
[Music]
do you want that
it will take about 30 minutes to get
them back here
[Music]
it's going to take 30 minutes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
well i think he was trying to give you a
conservative estimate so that we
wouldn't be
why don't you just check with him and
see what he thinks how far is the
village from here
there's a little place here
[Music]
let's
[Music]
[Music]
can we go down
[Music]
i know but where is it
i'd like to get some exercises
wait
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
oh he's in third grade
[Music]
study writing
yes they
yes he knows you're from america
[Music]
oh
what do they know about ever see any
americans here how about uh tingling
yeah
not yet yeah
only today's the first time
[Music]
[Music]
what do you like to do
[Music]
how many hours a day you go to school
three you don't set three and a half one
said three and the other said four
that's how
i asked why the difference in time he
says the variation of the grades as they
get higher than they study more
[Music]
they understand very well
they ever see a helicopter land here uh
by lantang sunday tour
over here
he wants to be a
like to be a doctor
okay
thank you
[Music]
i
oh
hey
[Music]
um
[Applause]
hot
using that
[Music]
[Music]
oh
he said he's very poor
me too i'm not
mike
hello
[Music]
again the year you were here
i was here in 1968-69
how did you feel about the war then when
you were here
increasingly disenchanted during the
time i was here um
we were we were
taking a fair amount of casualties and
and seeing an awful lot of action
without a sense of any gain for it there
was no
holding of territory no real
amassing of uh support if you will it
was kind of a very it was very random
and i thought uh almost irresponsible
so i i left here very very angry about
the way in which i thought life had been
uh put on the line without a real sense
of follow-through strategy understanding
of what we were involved in and so forth
and you started getting involved at what
point back in the states with the
vietnam veterans against well i guess i
went through a decompression stage and
kind of
stayed away from everything for a bit
and then i began to become involved in
it in uh
1970.
how long did you stay involved
uh
till the peace awards were signed and
the war basically ended
in the end who stopped the war
[Music]
oh i don't think i mean i don't think
any one thing stopped the war the war
kind of stopped itself
through all of its pieces the anti-war
movement the realities of the politics
the realities of the war itself
i think that
it just came to a grinding crunching
tortuous sort of end
based on all of the problems that were
raised by the war
which is why it was such a
tumultuous period of american history
what was life like over here at this
base for you what was a day like well we
didn't spend many days at that base we
were
the base was kind of an idyllic as you
saw
respite from the realities of the war
we'd come out to the base to get our
boats repaired
to have an overnight or two at this
barracks ship that we had there
uh refuel stock up be assigned your new
missions and then we'd set back into
this area to the delta
and ran through most of the canals and
rivers
of the delta at one point or another
were
we
very good at what we did i mean you hear
a lot of criticism about the american
fighting activity in this country what's
your opinion on that
oh i think the the fighters the warriors
were as good as they come i'm proud of
what we did i think i i was associated
with a group of guys who were as
competent and as brave and as
determined as any people i've ever been
associated with in my life and uh i love
that period
and them
for that kind of effort
on the other hand uh we were being asked
to do some
uh pretty impossible stuff given the
circumstances and the nature of the war
uh i i don't know any unit in vietnam
that didn't fight its heart out and
frankly
win
most of the battles we didn't lose the
battles he lost the war
and it was really politics and lack of
strategy and other things that i think
came to bite a lot of
good soldiers in the rear end and i
think that's why a lot of people still
carry a
frustration about it
what are you seeing
in these villages that you is it does it
look the same as it did when you were
here before yeah doesn't i mean just the
same
kid's the same as we have to say here
same same
um
oh the kids absolutely i mean these guys
used to just crowd around us we'd get
off our boats
and there'd be 30 or 40 kids standing
around you and
waiting and looking and francis says
there's somebody here only in those days
they used to say you number one
this is the local authority nowadays
they've lost that vernacular
but you know it was uh i was thinking as
i was flying over the water out there
you could see this extraordinary
turquoise see-through water
and these beautiful islands and we'd
come out of a
battle here
and then we go back in
and
you'd have this amazing chance just to
strip down skinny dip swim fish do what
you wanted to and so you had this
incredible
juxtaposition of life at its best and
then life at its worst
and i was thinking about it there was a
great sort of splendor of youth
and irresponsibility and there was a
great sorrow
in the downside of what we were doing
you want to interrupt you've got a
visitor i think okay
chinese
[Music]
[Music]
um
deputy director
for the um
[Music]
for the people's committee could you
tell him that we met yesterday with
general secretary doy moy
and with the minister of interior and
the minister of defense
and the foreign affairs minister in
hanoi
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
this gentleman is from the foreign
affairs ministry
of vietnam
so we would like to go into the village
foreign
foreign
they got the information that you were
coming but they got the information you
were coming to
so they prepared to receive you in
at nine in the morning yes in the
morning yeah
yeah in the morning
and uh but not now
yeah so they have nothing repaired now
i don't
[Music]
uh
um so uh when would you go right now
hong kong
[Music]
[Music]
how much time do you have here 15
minutes
the pilot says
[Music]
um
he hasn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes relatively near any foreigners in
that prison
no no no i'm gonna ask
[Music]
oh that was has been built recently more
recently after the
uh after the liberation of south vietnam
but there is a prison there uh yes yes
and is there another prison here
okay
okay
[Music]
yes there was one during the war against
the united
states i'd like to make the best use of
the time if if i could just i'd love to
just walk down here for a minute for 10
minutes
just for a few minutes
don't worry
you'll be
hello
oh
we don't want anybody run over tell them
be careful we don't want anybody in the
car uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
how long has he been working at this
below
has he ever seen any america has he ever
seen any americans here in this region
[Music]
he saw them in central vietnam uh before
1975. oh before 75 when i was living
there
were they part of the military effort
[Music]
since the war ended in 1975 has he seen
any americans anywhere
um
yes
[Music]
no sir
thank you very much ask her if she's
ever had that
i would love it but she said they were
here before before yeah ask her if she's
ever had so many people in her store
ask her if she's ever had so
um
very proud to have us here very happy
and proud thank you very much for
letting us visit
uh
careful of the truck here
francis
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
um
and when our people come back and he
knows about it
we have we look forward to cooperating
with him
today
[Music]
[Music]
because they had the plan to meet you at
hathian as you know but they uh this the
way we came in and when we came in and
where we came in was not in the plan i
understand i appreciate
[Music]
the province is ready to cooperate in
any way and he said of course if
anything uh anything wasn't just exactly
like it should have been due to any
oversights uh today or anything please
understand that that's the cause of the
situation keep working on it
be back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that concludes c-span's coverage of this
april fact-finding trip to vietnam
conducted by the senate select committee
on pow mia affairs
the committee returned to washington in
late april and has conducted several
subsequent hearings dealing with alleged
live siting reports of american soldiers
still listed as missing inaction
the committee must conclude its
investigation by the end of this session
of congress
ah
so
you